Welcome back for another episode
of Vintage Egyptologist. Today
we're going to be talking about scents,
perfumes, and incense in ancient Egypt.
And our sponsor today is none other
than Penhaligon's, a company with a
storied history going back to 1870 and the
holder of two royal warrants the first in 1903.
The reason why I want to begin with the concept
of royal warrants is because of King Hatshepsut
who not only used incense as a
way to legitimize her kingship,
but also dispatched an expedition
to put to fetch incense frankincense
and myrrh and commemorated that as one of
the signature achievements of her reign.
King Hatshepsut ruled between 1473 and 1458
bce. She was the daughter of a king Thutmose I
and a wife of another king Thutmose II. Upon the
death of Thutmose II, Hatshepsute essentially
takes over as regent ruling while Thutmose III is
a child However seven years into this arrangement
she actually declares herself king very possibly
because she had a very important ritual role the
god's wife of Amun, and also could trace back
her lineage to both the kings and the queens
of the late seventeenth dynasty Hatshepsut
uses some interesting means to legitimize
her kingship including a fascinating cycle of
reliefs at her temple on the west bank of Thebes
now called Deir el-Bahri. We call
these scenes the divine birth cycle
these images and texts claim that the god al
moon is actually Hatshepsut's father and this
goes back to the very beginnings of Egyptian
kingship where the king was believed to be
the earthly incarnation at first the god Horus
and soon after the sun god Ra by the time of the
middle kingdom the god Amun of Thebes who then
becomes the imperial god of the New Kingdom is
closely associated with kingship but Hatshepsut's
reign is the first time that we have these images
preserved in this way with these hieroglyphic
annotations so how does Amun engendering the
future king Hatshepsut relate to perfume? in this
scene we see Amun on the left his crown is mostly
damaged but we know from many many other examples
of Amun that he would have been wearing a crown
with two tall ostrich plumes and on the right
we see queen Ahmose who is Hatshepsut's mother
Ahmose and Amun's legs are crossed and he is
giving the sign of life both to her nostrils and
into her palm these are subtle ways in which the
Egyptians express intimacy the hieroglyphic text
is a bit more explicit quote words spoken by
Amun-Ra lord of the thrones of the two lands
foremost of his private apartment after he made
his transformation into the majesty of this her
husband Thutmose given life so that is how
Amun Ra gains entry into the queen's bedroom
he transforms into the king into Thutmose the
first the hieroglyphic text then continues
he Amun found her the queen as she was
resting in the interior of the palace
she awakened because of the divine
aroma and she smiled before his majesty
so what gives the god away what indicates to the
queen that it is Amun and not her husband Thutmose
the first is how he smells after the actual
divine conception occurs we read how quote
love of him coursed through all of her limbs
and the palace was inundated with divine aroma
every one of his sense was from
point and this topped him punt
is fascinating because that is the origin of so
many of the materials that the ancient Egyptians
used to create their own sense it is difficult
to pinpoint exactly the ancient location of point
however we know from Hatshepsut's reliefs that
she dispatched a maritime expedition she had ships
built dismantled taken across the eastern desert
probably on the Wadi Hammamat road reassembled
and launched south along the red sea and we have
fabulous depictions of the sorts of fish that the
sailors encountered when the Egyptian expedition
brought back from point unto you trees trees
that would produce the incense that would be
burnt upon the altars of temples throughout Egypt
we know that by doing this was fulfilling the
promises that she made to her divine father Amun
the ancient Egyptians had several
different words for incense
the main word is sennetjer which literally means
to make divine so the root nature meaning god
or netjer divine with a causative s prefix
thus to make divine another word for incense
the Egyptians use is kapet and that root refers to
smoke or burning and it's really interesting that
the ancient Egyptian word kapet thus has the same
etymology of our word perfume which goes back to
Latin meaning through smoke because the easiest
way to release a scent in antiquity was through
burning in addition to temple ritual burning
incense for the gods the ancient Egyptians
also used scents during celebrations and this is
where we get that concept of the perfume infused
wax cones that people would place on top of
their wigs during giant festival celebrations
the tomb painting is a brilliant example of how
ancient Egyptian art is full of scents we can see
the scented wax cones that both the man
and his wife are wearing but we also see
floral collars beneath their chairs
and another great indication of scent
are the lotus blossoms also decorating the
women's wigs so when we see art like this it's
not just an indication of the visual richness
of a festival celebration or hear a funerary
banquet but the images themselves are redolent
with the sweet smells of the ancient Nile valley
when the ancient Egyptians made perfumes
what they were actually creating were scented
ungents and oils because at that point in
antiquity distillation had not been invented
meaning that you could not have alcohol-based
perfumes as we have today and has certainly
existed by the middle ages but there's even
an Egyptian connection here because it appears
that the process of distillation which required a
certain type of glassware was actually created by
a female alchemist who lived in Alexandria in the
first couple of centuries CE Maria of Alexandria
the alchemist thus set the stage for later
developments of distillation and perfumes
that we can enjoy today such as the remarkable
historical and trade routes collections
at Penhaligon's in future episodes we're going to
dive deeper into the ancient Egyptian origins of
alchemy going beyond the work of maria of
alexandria and Zozomos of Panopolis into how
metallurgists and miners of the pharaonic era
set the intellectual stage for the deep alchemical
reflections that we see in later authors